I had no passion
in my career okay this was a chosen
career like I started my own business in
the category in a profession that I
thought I wanted to spend the rest of my
life in and to wake up one morning with
a superficially good life and didn't
want to do it anymore right it's kind of
distressing because when we started you
know so many of us intertwined our
identities with our work and if I don't
like my work then who am I
so I went through that and it was the
discovery of this little idea that I
called the Golden Circle we all know
what we do some of us know how we do it
but very few of us know why we do what
we do and I realized I didn't know why I
was doing what I was doing
and it was that crisis that was designed
to do nothing more than help me find my
own passion to get back my mojo that put
me in a path that was unexpected